alors restez tranquilles et laissez-nous
faire le soulageant je peux savoir
classe vous restez vous êtes il vous
plait on essaie de contrôler ses moyens
pour être sûrs qu'ils sont clean ouais
mais je suis désolé c'est pas des bons
rien hockey ce sont ce sont des artistes
des artistes vous avez dit vous êtes
sérieux la wii gajan d'artistes mais
rappeur n'a travaillé avec moi au studio
en ce moment d'abord le rap n'est pas un
art et vous êtes qui vous leur manager
bah vous perdez votre temps monsieur le
manager vous foutez de moi je dis vous
perdez bras dans vos clients là cette
vapeur
ouais on dirait les membres d'un gang de
quel droit vous venez arrêter des gens
juste parce que leur tête ne vous
revient pas cette malade ça s'appelle du
harcèlement vous avez dit que vous étiez
leur manager et n'avait qu'un constat
chose quelque chose de quel droit vous
débarquer ici est agressé ses garçons
parce qu'ils ont la peau noire